so we have this function that's equal to
2 minus 8 x squared plus 32 x to the
fourth minus 128
x to the sixth and just keeps going and
going so it's defined as an
infinite series and what i want to
explore in this video is there another
way to
write this function so it's not
expressed as an infinite series well
some of you might be thinking
well this looks like a geometric series
on the right hand side an
infinite geometric series and we know
what the sum of an infinite
geometric series is if it converges
so maybe that's way a way that we can
express this so let's try to do that so
first let's just confirm that this is an
infinite geometric series
in order for it to be a geometric series
each successive term
has to be some common ratio times the
previous term
so to go from 2 to negative 8x squared
what do you have to multiply by
well you have to multiply by negative 4
x squared now let's see if you multiply
negative 8x squared times negative
4x squared what do you get well negative
4 times negative 8 is positive 32
x squared times x squared is x to the
fourth so that works and then you
multiply that times
negative 4x squared and you indeed would
get negative 128x to the sixth
so this indeed looks like an infamous
infinite geometric series on the right
hand side in fact
we can rewrite f of x as
being equal to the sum from
n equals 0 to infinity
of you have your first term and then you
have your common ratio
negative 4 x squared to the
nth power let's confirm that works when
n equals 0
this is going to be 1 so 2 times 1 is 2
and that indeed
is our first term there and then to that
you're going to add it
to when n is equal to 1 so that's just
going to be 2 times negative 4 x squared
which is indeed
this second term right over here and so
this looks like it works
now what is the sum of
an infinite geometric series like this
well it's going to be a finite value
assuming
the absolute value of your common ratio
is less than one so first of all let's
just think about under what conditions
is the absolute value of our common
ratio less than one
and then we could say okay that helps us
to find a radius
of convergence and then if x
is in though in that in that zone or if
it's in that interval
then we can figure out a non-infinite
geometric series way of expressing
this function so if we just think about
under what circumstances will this
converge will it come out to a finite
value
that's a situation in which the absolute
value of your common ratio
is less than one and so let's see if we
can simplify this a little bit
and any no matter what x is it's always
going to be not x squared is always
going to be non-negative
and so the only so this entire
expression is always going to be
negative and so if you take the absolute
value of it this is going to be
evaluate as 4 x squared which is always
going to be positive
so this is equivalent to 4x squared
which needs to be less than 1
or we could say that x squared needs to
be less than
1 4 or we could say
that x needs to be
less than one-half and greater than
negative one-half one way to think about
it is
anywhere in this interval if you square
it you're going to be less than
one-fourth
at one-half if you square it it's equal
to one-fourth and at negative one-half
if you square it it's equal to
one-fourth but for
lower absolute values it's going to be
less than one-fourth and so that's what
this interval right here says another
way to think about it is the absolute
value of x
needs to be less than one half and so
we've just defined
an interval over which this infinite
geometric series will converge
you could say this has a radius of
convergence of
let me write it this way radius of
convergence convergence
of one half you can go one half above
zero and one half
below zero but now that we've set the
conditions under which this would
converge
let's rewrite it so this function is
going to be equal to
we know what the sum of an infinite
geometric series is
it's going to be equal to the first term
over
1 minus your common ratio
1 minus negative 4 x squared
and so we can rewrite our function as f
of x
is equal to 2 over 1 subtract a negative
1 plus
4 x squared for
the absolute value of x is less than
one-half we have the interval over which
we converge
and there you have it we are
done